Pacifica nigga see with a will is
Pacifica Pacifica uh I've already
forgotten oh no there's a okay there's a
couple coats so much we keep reading to
bring out the now I'm gonna take my
shirt here and cut a W neck get tell
your servant to you know there's W neck
it looks good just like you know yes
whoa uh I give me gonna bring up now
there's a page at the end of every
episode with a bunch of various code so
I'm just I'm kind of we keying this so
I'm just gonna do the ones that you know
are the funniest debugger isn't that
kind of cheating yes
she's rich she cheats at life so okay so
first one is a old man sleeping on the
green can't help but wonder what he's
seen obviously talking about mcgucket uh
but my absolute favorite is remember big
Henry yeah
body is barred dude what's with all the
pictures of naked Wendy on your brush H
right next to the toy incest odd euro
telethia is funny not cool Oh soon um
all right so this is Gulf War uh
answering the question every little kid
has had what Gore is not fun owes a mini
golf ball since this is friend what goes
on in those mini golf uh setups and
houses and castles and stuff and I just
said I knew it I knew it y'all doing
here it's just the show finally
confirmed kick that thing into the damn
windmill and it doesn't come out right
and you know something's going on in
there yeah I think everyone either
thought there's like some sort of
complicated like wily coyote machine or
little people doing something in there
and this answers it because Mabel and
Pacifica they get in this this
competition where they're trying to see
who's the best golfer and they
discovered the little people inside that
do all the stuff with the with the golf
balls a little different nationality
yeah they all match solution is
equipment they all match their
attraction which just makes that so much
funnier how easy would have been just to
have them all look the same and talk to
the guys they gave them the
personalities and the different themes
and stuff and it's so funny the guy
speaking the French gibberish and
don't translate sytem exit um and so
Mabel and dipper Reigate to try and get
to that the win while influencing their
war because their Lilly worry I gotcha
ins yeah it brilliant buddy or spelled
out it's just brilliant
oh and he can't say it right but it's
like he knows it's like no type that
this was a writer's problem cuz it looks
funny written out so each assessment oh
the imagination on display in this show
never ceases to amaze well I think this
one just Kim their little worlds but the
best joke though when they kick it into
the mine begin Henry oh I got this yeah
this whole love tragic looks corny and
back little Polly and he actually dies
that's why I love pacifically man is
really taking awhile for this ball
become epic is before he kills Augie
opens up the picture within a little
Polly little here at any time
I should land so hard in a horrific
death but my god that is the funniest
thing I've ever seen
it's the him saying he'll do it and then
the immediate huge big eyed little girl
can I got do a little party what what's
your name little Polly yeah we're gonna
do a little Polly vagina thing rains
gonna the good I just love it cuz we
know there's like this incredible
backstory to them like how they met
maybe he was like you know this outsider
people may follow that she's like no you
can't do animation to never bear and so
like he came in to help raiser and
something this is this big this is the
climax did like has incredible movie a
joke worthy of any of the great cartoon
shows I feel like I would have seen that
on Futurama or sentence or some like
yeah yeah just and how quickly a went to
just you know that gas leak is there um
come in to do it
Scott laughing I was just up I was
applauding and I couldn't breathe and
then the allottee stares at the picture
just letting go back and then the ball
just comes on the coop yeah great are we
going to you know let's get us sewed on
I love that pit soda actually has pizza
I I never I always forget about the pit
IIIi don't know if that was like always
the joke as I was always like pit sowed
I just didn't get it and that's like oh
there's actually a pit in it so uh the
stars are really pretty tonight okay
that's got weird I'm out of here hey
Seuss once again what if I thing is that
if I had to guess though you never do
scene with a woman it's like I would
guess he's not actually gay he's more
like just getting caught up in the
moment
I think he's no no no no I think he's
asexual no no I forgot cuz there's an
episode comes up but actually it he does
have some interesting issues I mean not
necessarily like you know gay or bi or
anything but it's like there's there's
definitely issues that come up I would
just assume he's like a plant he's
asexual baby
oh no they address it and it's it's one
my favorite episode that's gonna be
really fun but oh okay anywho uh yeah we
pretty much just talked about this after
that this is the one that has the ending
that somebody actually took and did an
anime version of it like a really
fucking well done animated version of
them in anime just the drive home and it
it just looks like one of those dramatic
animes you seen where it's like no no
this one's just about you know high
schoolers connecting or something like
that and it's really well done I'll look
it up anything like gravity falls anime
I like me some animes ya know it's I
mean it's it's a weird scene to choose
all the two Jem guys came bad yeah the
judge came back hurry somebody got
burned I love the little mini high fives
with the finger and said you know I'll
say this uh from a character standpoint
I really like how at the end you know
they're about to give her a drive and
dipper shakes his head like don't do it
don't know I really like that they still
keep the characters like no they're
gonna have their hatred for certain
characters like no matter what it's not
all going to come where everybody's
happy and cheerful you know even some
people too
I like being every um selling tress
MacNeille what did they do get her just
for that small part for charities like
that sounds very bad bunny um but uh
yeah I love the idea of this one I love
the little golf people uh you know what
the one downside I mean I really mean
that in like the most nitpicky is way
but the one downside to the show is you
immediately know what the lessons gonna
be at the end and maybe that is the
Disney factor you know that is something
that at your time like just really has
all over the show is that their lessons
are so much more interesting in complex
you know we're this one is like kids
yeah it's it is one of those things it's
like fair enough I mean everything else
is just so good and I guess happy morals
I'm totally fine with morals and these
are very everyone so well though the
mean vindictive site amis just like
can't she just win once so that seems to
be the pattern is Pacifica always wins
um I kind of like that though I know but
somebody's like maple represent like no
moral high ground is always the hardest
I know I but I like that cuz it's like
you know yeah Mabel doesn't win but
she's happy we're Pacifica is always
piss off and you know I I told you know
so she is winning I just you wait but
sometimes you know it would just be
satisfying it had it's not yet into I
mean I not the more like need it's just
the one I want okay and Mabel cheated
too you know I think that's you don't be
part of it too I love that when they're
leaving like she let's see here is my
issue though Mabel was cheating but
wasn't they're not intentional cheating
but weren't they hinting that you know
when you kick it into the window or
something it never comes out quite right
because of what's going on in there so
there was a weird sort of randomness to
maybe I don't know um I do like how when
they're leaving the golf course like
there's edge it's kind of like surviving
like a giant golf car like the exes
coming down and stop I mean it's like
well to be giant axes to cut up people
um patton oswalt as the leader there who
we thought was maybe the Inca
suitable guy from Princess Bride he was
driving I heard it enough out like know
that that's that know I started figured
out I'm like I'm thinking of a Pixar
movie and I can't remember which but I
was like I've heard this voice before
yeah so goodness area earnest way of
speaking of my all ratatouille I mean
I'm sure like he anytime they need him
I'm sure you sign the contract like
anytime we need you for a character
you're coming back a lot like for the
rants and I'm doing a stand of a no-good
trash down her you know we owe you as
well yes sir with four fingers a song
keep with you um but but let me hear
between the lines uh but but it's great
ivy it's like he's still a wonderful
added um and yeah just a really creative
Disney cryogenically freezes all their
stars and just thaws them out when they
need them yeah you know what I also like
we need a guest star follows mom well
step on it and get me some cheddar well
what I like is uh you think there's like
cheese vodka like alcoholic cheese shots
or something like that yeah you got
wonder that Mickey has like stashed away
um it it is high it's just like it they
can pull the plug on us anytime they
want good it's like that we do
technically work we're just daring
really yeah it's that we should probably
nicer but we're gonna phone call he's
like a trap
no I'll shut up but make your cat the
cool thing about Disney is that they
could do the same thing of gravity falls
cuz they like with the boy bands and
stuff like oh god that was Hayley
totally at Disney yeah I mean and
Disney's just been fine with it so like
I said I don't I don't know where this
major change is happening like I said
with like wreckit-ralph frozen and
gravity falls and stuff but it's like
it's some sort of change is happening
and it's it's friggin great oh I don't
care what you do hurts just so long as
you have those two twins kissing we're
gon set them in a choco bar so I will
make it a tie in um so yeah uh it's a
really fun Oh what I'll say about the
climax is I love how it's like you know
a cutter open get that sticker and stuff
and they untier and they get away so
that could be your climax but no they
decide to get in the car and they keep
going to go through like the obstacle
course and stuff I love there's always
like an extra little climax that you
really welcome it's
not like it's another - Mabel Moen where
she like swings down the string of
lights with the golf club and she's like
yeah it's one of those things where it's
like issue you know reminds me of member
and Aliens when it's like okay Shack
yeah okay like quit it canvas playing
with aliens but do you know anything
about cheese camera movies you know
there's always another ending but with
James Cameron's movies it's like you're
kinda happy there's another ending like
it is a 2-1 we're and they're all like a
Michael Bay film where there's eight
endings and it just like oh Christ will
this battle just dad yeah we're and
that's why I feel like gravity falls
it's like it's like there's always can't
- climaxes but it's like I want that our
climates cuz I'm having so much fun it's
it stays just the right edge what she
said uh-huh um twincest but ya know I I
thought this was a really fun episode oh
swatch alert this episode was brought to
you by the sweater golf like yeah lag
though I think this one there were two
cuz didn't she have a different one on
before they went golfing hey Jay I can't
remember I thought it was like a star or
something maybe I think so but yeah so
that's our swatch alert for the day
innocence and always remember you're the
star we're required to say that I
actually hate all of you trap